We begin with
important news just in to CNN.
The debt
limit talks on Capitol Hill
hitting a snag this morning.
The top Republican negotiator
walking out of a meeting
saying the White House stance
is unreasonable.
Congressman Garrett Graves
says talks for now are, quote, on pause.
That just a few hours
after President Biden
was briefed by his top negotiators
the president leaving a G7 leaders dinner
in Japan early for that update.
And less than 24 hours ago,
Team Biden
and the Republican House Speaker
Kevin McCarthy
both voicing optimism
saying they were seeing progress
in those talks
so that one member of the centrist
Problem Solvers Caucus,
everyone is not going to be happy
with everything that's to.
Always a good deal
if everyone's a little upset
and you know
it's not going to be perfect.
But the bottom line is we're going
to make sure
that the full faith and credit
United States continues
Let's get straight to
CNN's Melody and Ana.
She's live on Capitol Hill.
Melody, early in the morning,
there was optimism. What happened?
Well, this is a huge setback
for these talks.
There was optimism,
as you noted, yesterday,
even heading into this meeting.
Negotiators did meet
this morning on Capitol Hill,
but they briefly broke up
and coming out of that meeting,
Garret Graves,
one of the lead negotiators
for Republicans, told us we do.
We decided to press pause
because it's just not productive.
So I talked to some sources
who said
there are
a number of issues
where they just feel like
they're at an impasse right now.
And as of right now,
there are no additional meetings
scheduled for today.
So, look, John,
you've seen these negotiators
play out before.
Usually there are legislative blowups
before everyone
can finally come together.
There's a lot of posturing
that goes on in both sides.
And as we've seen, both Republicans
and Democrats are facing
a lot of pressure
and getting a lot of heat from their
right and left
flanks to not cave and to dig in.
But in terms of a timeline,
it is very problematic
because they were hoping to reach a deal
by this weekend.
That is something that Speaker
Kevin McCarthy said
is needed
in order
to get this bill through the floor
and get it over to the Senate
by this early June deadline.
And so it is all but dashing hopes
that negotiators are going to be able
to reach a deal
in principle by this weekend.
That's not to say that
they can't eventually get it done.
But this is not a very welcome
development on Capitol Hill John.
And Mel, any details?
Sometimes it's one little thing
that can set these things
off the rails for a little bit.
Sometimes it's kind of a combination
that they're stuck on everything
and they just say, let's take a break.
Do we know?
Yeah, I think it's more the latter.
It's a combination of issues.
The talks had been slowly
but surely moving ahead.
Some of the issues
that have come up in the last 24 hours,
according to our sources.
The White House here
in pushing for a debt ceiling hike
that would last into 2025
because they don't want
have to deal with this again
until after the next
presidential election.
But in talking to Republicans
that is something
that if we're going to entertain that
we need to see
a lot more savings and cuts
put on the table.
The other issue at play
has been work requirements.
That's
something Republicans are pushing for.
Biden seems to be open
to some form of work
requirements for Tanna,
which is the Temporary Assistance
for Needy Families programs.
But nothing has been finalized.
So still a lot to go
and a lot that could go wrong
between now and early June John.
Senator, appreciate the hustle
and the breaking news on Capitol Hill.
Keep us posted if we learn anything else.
With me in studio
to share their reporting
and their insights, CNN's Jeff Zeleny.
Brianna Sotomayor of The Washington Post
and Joe, still in The New York Times.
So this is both expected, I would say,
because the issues are so important
and the divide is so big.
But also
potentially troubling
if you're a CEO,
if you're financial markets,
if you're the president,
United States,
who's overseas right now
telling people,
I got this, America will not default
without question.
I mean, all signs
had been pointed to an agreement,
which was actually
a little surprising
because that does not usually happen
sort of going into a weekend.
But I think that one thing this is doing
We've only known about this
for a short time,
but already the sense of urgency,
I think perhaps from Wall Street
may change on this.
We'll see what the market does today.
But heading into the weekend,
this is not the place
where the White House
thought they would be.
You heard the optimism
from Josh Gottheimer there,
the congressman from New Jersey.
So, look,
this often happens
there are some hiccups,
but it is the work requirements
that is causing the White House
a lot of grief from the left.
And so that's the advice here
that they find themselves.
And to that point, when you see
Josh Schottenheimer saying,
I think we're going to get there
and to get there still,
when you see both the president
and the House speaker
saying we're suddenly making progress,
that's a conversation in the middle.
And so both the left and the right say,
oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
And so let's start with the left.
You have Democrat progressive saying,
stop negotiating, Mr.
President, invoke the 14th Amendment.
Never really been tested in the courts.
But just say, you know,
the Constitution says the amendment says
the public debt can never be questioned.
Bernie Sanders
among the progressives are saying,
we don't want cuts. Take a chance
Using the 14th Amendment
would allow
the United States to continue
to pay its bills on time
and without delay,
prevent an economic catastrophe
and prevent
devastating cuts
to some of the most
vulnerable people in this country.
It should be exercised if necessary.
So, again, we go into the details.
But if you're the White House team,
you're walking back
into the meeting today,
even though you're making progress.
You know, the phones are lighting up
with progressives saying, stop.
Don't give away too much.
And they have been they have been. Right.
I mean,
they've already been feeling the pressure
from the left flank,
particularly after last weekend
when the president cited
the fact that he did vote
for some work requirements as a senator
right before he left on his trip as well.
He had comments where he said,
look, you know,
we're talking about work requirements,
but it wouldn't be of
anything of serious consequence.
He has dropped hints
that that is a subject,
a point of focus
now where there could be
possible consensus,
which has led to a frustrated left
flank of the party at this point.
But remember,
in terms of using the 14th Amendment,
this is also somebody
and President Biden that came into office
and often
celebrated, talked
about his ability to strike deals
with members on the other side.
So would you
when you look at that context
Is he really going to go for this option?
Green job here the other day
also said
that he didn't think
that would be an ultimate solution
for what we're seeing. Right.
They want to talk it out.
And again, just yesterday,
the House speaker,
if you could put the negotiators
back up,
number one, Garret Graves is his trusted
deputy among House Republicans.
But the House speaker
complimented the White House team saying,
I like these people,
I trust these people.
We can get it done.
That sent a signal to McCarthy's right.
And of course,
he is just tenuously speaker of the House
Freedom Caucus yesterday
saying the US House of Representatives
has done its job.
There should be no further discussion
until the Senate passes legislation.
So the speaker's right flank saying stop,
we don't like this. Nice talk.
Yeah, it's
been a very interesting contrast
this entire week
because McCarthy has been using
every moment possible to say
things are going well.
Look, all Republicans are united.
He couldn't stop saying that on repeat,
while at the same time behind the scenes
concern ratings
were starting to get pretty shaky.
They were worried at Garrett Graves
actually being tapped.
They see him
as someone who is just a dealmaker.
So they already had a feeling
that their bill that they passed,
they know a lot of it
is not going to become law,
but they really did
do not see graves
as someone who could deliver
on a lot of what the freedom
caucus wants.
So this
statement that they put out yesterday
strategically
after they left, after even
they were being very complimentary
of where things are,
is really bigger
I think we should be looking at it more
as to what this means
for these next steps.
And clearly,
clearly, Graves
is now listening and saying,
maybe we should pause,
maybe we should pause.
And now the question is is it
just a pause?
Is it a hiccup or is it a problem?
And we'll continue to report that out.